Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. [music] The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent
[music] any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the individual
sharing their testimony. Results [music]
vary and may not be typical. We do not
make any claims regarding health or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to have the founding father of
the science of epigenetics guiding us
with the best options to obtain or
maintain optimal health, Dr. Joel
Wallik.
Oh. Hello everybody and welcome to daily
with Dr. Becca. My name is Becca Dukes
and I am so excited as we have the
holidays coming up and all of the things
that that brings with the joy and the
comfort and in that joy and comfort
sometimes includes some of those comfort
foods that maybe aren't eaten all year
long. But maybe we need to think about
that. So we're going to be thinking
about that a little bit as we are making
the holiday sweet. but not raising our
blood sugar, folks. Here on dailywithdoc
and Becca. Now, this program is being
sponsored by dailywithdoc.com.
On dailywithdoc.com, you're going to
find a good foods, bad foods list.
You're going to find replays from our
previous presentations and Zooms and
podcasts, whatever you want to call
this. And you're also going to find on
there um other articles that help you as
an individual get information that you
can use in your everyday life. So it's
not just some technical jargon that you
may never use. Kind of like what we talk
about algebra. Well, I used a lot of
algebra and statistics. So pay attention
kids. But we are also going to be
talking about how
each and every day we need to be mindful
about what we put in our body and what
we can do to support our body in every
situation. So, especially here in the
holidays, I love baking. And we're going
to talk about some of those things,
alternatives also that you can do in
your baking to make it healthier for you
and your family and those you love.
[snorts] So, if you were invited by
somebody specific, we want to make sure
that you get back with the person that
shared this program with you. They cared
enough to share this program. so care
enough and tell tell them thank you for
taking the time. They are also going to
be the person that you get back to with
any questions. All right. So, as we have
our shows, we get lots of questions in
the chat. If you're watching us on a
live stream off of Zoom and you have
some questions, you're more than welcome
to put those questions in that chat if
that is available. Also, let us know
where you're joining us from. Now, if
you'd like to join us here live in the
Zoom, and if you're here already, make
sure that you have that chat open. The
information that is being spoken,
Marilyn does a tremendous job and doing
transcription in putting that in the
chat as well, including recommendations
as we go through the show that Dr.
Wallik makes for individuals with the
certain health or health conditions and
symptoms. So, we do go by symptoms and
conditions, um, not necessarily medical
jargon.
With that being said,
um, we are here Monday through Friday
from 12:00 to 1:00 p.m. Pacific time.
That's two mountain, 3 central, and no,
one mountain, 2 central, 3 Eastern. And
we are here for you and for you, the
people that you love. So, make sure you
share this program with them because
folks, there's so much information out
on the internet. Some of it, okay, no,
I'm not going to say some of it. Most of
it when it comes to nutrition,
they're just mocking what the doctor
that we have on here with us has been
saying for over three decades. Let's say
over four decades, maybe even five
decades.
>> Five.
Five. Okay. So, has it been five decades
since you taught nutrition, Dr. Wallik,
at the Natural Pathic College in Oregon?
>> Oh, yeah. I started teaching in 1965.
>> N Wow. So, folks, the man that I'm going
to bring on the screen with me right now
is Dr. Joel Wallik. Now, Dr. Wallak has
a bachelor of science in plant and soil
sciences. He is also a doctor of
veterary medicine. He has three
postdoates
in pathology.
He is also also a naturopathic
physician.
Now, through all of his experience,
he has been able to be very instrumental
in sa saving the white rhino as a head
veterinarian
on that expedition with Marlon Perkins
of Mutual Omaha's Wild Kingdom. He
[snorts] has also identified the cause
of liver cancer in bears in zoos around
the world.
So, so if they're around the world,
chances are they're not related and
they're different species of bears, but
they all being fed the same thing and
coming up with liver cancer. He figured
it out in a very short amount of time.
They made
>> five five days, like I said, a very
short amount of time. out [snorts] 5
days figuring out what was the cause and
even identified
the aspiggillis that was on the peanuts
that were being fed to the bears which
then includes aphletoxin which is
cancercausing.
So folks recently there was something
that was on the news
alert aphletoxin found in peanuts causes
cancer. God's been saying that for 50
years. It's nothing new, folks. So,
let's make sure that the person that is
bringing this information
gets the credit. And Dr. Wallik, you
have not gotten nearly the amount of
credit that you should. Even a note you
have received the Claus Schwarz award in
2011. You also received the award from
United Nations.
>> Lifetime achievement award for United
Nations.
>> A lifetime achievement award.
Absolutely. Um they should be given
award for individuals who sue the FDA
eight times and win. That that should be
an award in itself. Some of the things
that others get Nobel Peace prizes for,
Dr. wall are just
ridiculous in comparison to what you
have done for humanity. So I want to
make sure that everybody gets this
information and is able to apply it
because that's what we do. We provide
information that is applicable to
everybody
around the world. So [snorts]
Dr. Wallik.
And for those of you who don't know,
cystic fibrosis
was said to be a human condition and it
was said to be genetic. He found the
first nonhuman case of cystic fibrosis
in a Reesei monkey. And actually almost
all of the young monkeys in that
community were not related and they all
had cystic fibrosis.
it was the diet, but they didn't want to
hear that, so they fired him. And that
actually, Dr. Wallik, led you on to such
greater accomplishments, bigger and
better things as you took the place of
Jeffrey Bland, who is a very well-known
individual in the nutrition realm. He
was the last PhD that was received under
Lionus Pauling
who both of you are students of Lionus
Pauling.
>> Yes.
>> You took his position at the
naturopathic college in Oregon and
started teaching nutrition. You didn't
>> National College of Naturopathic
Medicine and CNN.
>> There you go. National College of
Naturopathic Medicine which has changed
names since. But
Dr. Wick, you have learned from some of
the best. You have created and you're
one of the founding co-founding fathers
of the science of epigenetics.
And Jeffrey Bland even wrote the forward
for epigenetics.
This is epigenetics. This is one of Dr.
Wallik's books. This is a Reesei monkey
that I was talking about earlier. I mean
just just so endearing. Dr. while
it also shows you with the uh Claw
Schwarz ward being presented by who's
this to dear Hel.
So
yes. So folks, we're in great company
right now as we are students of an
amazing teacher, doctor, lecturer,
researcher,
and Dr. What goes into getting a
post-doate in pathology?
Well, um you have to um
um uh be there every day, seven days a
week, and you're doing autopsies. You're
looking at slides of the tissues uh and
you're learning what's going on in
pathology. And I actually received two
nominations for a Nobel Prize because of
all that. And um was very very honored
for that. And of course, um, everybody
on the Nobel Prize committee was a
medical doctor. And so when an Hopic
doctor came up to actually get the award
after I was nominated for it, they said,
"This guy's not even a medical doctor.
He's a he's an indie. We're not going to
give him the Nobel Prize." But just
being nominated was a beautiful thing. I
cannot thank those teams enough for
nominating me for the Nobel Prize. It
just tells you that they appreciated
that I was doing something very, very
special for humanity.
>> Well, you know, even though you didn't
get the actual Nobel Prize, I think you
have done more for humanity, like I said
earlier, than any one person, Dr.
Wallik. And that's why I believe so much
in this message because of the changes
that it made in my own life and those
that I'm seeing in my clients each and
every day. I mean, there's no there's
nothing greater than getting a phone
call from a client that just is so
excited
because their blood pressure is normal
without pharmaceuticals.
Or they don't have to do kidney dialysis
three days a week anymore.
or they have a kiddo who wasn't able to
pay attention in school
now able to function and one particular
one
on the the autism spectrum
struggled during high school. We got him
on the program. He went to college and
graduated from college with honors.
Folks, that's the importance and what
quality nutrition can do for you and
those in your family. So, Dr. Wallock,
let's go to blood sugar.
Okay, as we're coming into the holidays,
there's cookies, there's cakes, there's
pies, there's sugar added to even the
good foods like sweet potatoes
making it so that it's actually on the
harmful side to our body.
What can we do, Dr. Wallik? Um, I mean,
of course, there's there's foods that we
can substitute out and all of those
cookies, cakes, pies, what's their main
ingredient?
>> This is very easy.
>> This is very easy to protect yourself.
Uh, obviously just not eat anything with
sugar in it. But that's not going to
happen with all the holidays and all the
treats and desserts, desserts and cakes
and pies and drinks and so forth.
That's why we came up with Sweeties,
which has the nutrients in it that help
control blood sugar. We take people
who've been treated as a diabetic by the
medical profession for 25 years. In two
weeks time on this product and the 90,
you just can't use this by itself. This
this goes along with the 90. Okay? It
could be the healthy start pack. There
you go. The healthy start pack or the
healthy brain and heart pack or the
healthy bone and joint pack. any one of
those three uh total programs get all 90
essential nutrients, 16 minerals, 16
vitamins, 12, and three fatty acids. You
can add the sweeties. Okay? And I I've
done that when we first came out with
it. I've been taking three of those
twice a day for like 30 years.
And um it helps you control your blood
sugar. Uh, and like I say, we have so
many diabetics who've been injecting
insulin for like 25 years and then in
two to four weeks they're not a diabetic
anymore because they're taking the
sweeties which is what was missing. It
was a deficiency disease, not a genetic
thing. And then of course we have also
to a lot of sweeties.
>> Let's can can we go back to that
statement that you just made? Diabetes
is not a genetic thing. It's not
something that because your grandmother
and your mother and your father and
grandfather, one of them had it, that
you're going to get it.
>> No. See, it has to do with if everybody
in the family is eating grandma's
recipes and they have a disease, it's
grandma's recipe that caused it. It's
not the genetics. There's no genetics
that causes diabetes. Okay? And then, of
course, um it's very, very simple. Like
I say, we take people who have spent
most of their life, 25, 30 years as
diabetic and they're getting they're so
excited because they can inject insulin
once or twice a day, but then they're
failing. Their body is failing because
they're missing these nutrients and they
can't store uh energy. And so that's why
we came up with the sweeties and the
oceans gold for the thyroid, the
sweeties for your pancreas
and the blood sugar levels. And it works
99.9% of the time. The only time it
doesn't work if somebody's didn't give
up the bad foods and they cannot absorb
the nutrients in Swedes or Oceans Gold
because they've killed the villi in
their intestines. Instead of looking
like a shag rug, the villi are gone.
Okay, there you go.
>> So go ahead and finish about the villi.
instead of being like a shag rug. And
this is the inside the intestines,
folks. So I don't have
>> intestine is a tube, but the tube is
lined with these finger-like projections
called villi. You look it up in many
dictionaries or just ask Siri, okay,
what is villi? V I L L I E. Okay, what
are what are villi? They're the
finger-like projections that take and
add 90% more surface area for
absorption. And they also have little
villi, little um um hairs on them, okay,
that help move food along along with the
muscles, okay? And so um this is
something that when you eat gluten,
wheat butter and oats and buckwheat
pancakes, we used to eat buckwheat
pancakes on like one Saturday or Sunday
a month. And then once I found out about
the the buckwheat causing the same thing
as wheat, brother, I know everybody
stopped eating buckwheat. Okay, of
course that's an an English thing. It
started out in England was the buckwheat
kind of thing, but sweeties oceans gold,
but that's again not to replace the 90s
nutrients. These are add-ons. Uh and and
when the holidays are over, just keep
taking them. Don't stop taking them. And
you'll add many healthful years to your
life if you take these things because
they will help you control blood sugar.
They'll help you control energy levels
and storage of energy and the ability to
acquire it when you need it. Uh those
two products are very very useful in
modern times. And of course we have 25
bestsell actually 27 bestselling books
and we have this new tool out now. Um
okay it's a DVD. It's not a CD, it's a
DVD. And this was actually encouraged by
uh Charlie Ward, who is probably one of
the the biggest people in Europe, maybe
the world, when it comes to news and
health information and so forth. And um
he came and listened to some of my
lectures and so forth. We did some
things together. And so, uh, he
encouraged me to find out what's going
on with AI, artificial intelligence.
And artificial intelligence, when you
look at your thermostat in your wall,
that's AI. But when you're asleep and
let's say you have it set for 75 and it
gets cold outside and the temperature in
the house drops down to 60, it kicks in.
So, is it in the thermostat and the heat
heater turns on, brings it back up to
75. Or if it's too hot in the summertime
and it goes up to 80, it brings it back
down to 75 or 70, okay, with um the uh
cooling system and you're asleep. That's
AI. That's artificial intelligence doing
that. You didn't have to sit there and
do the switch, you know, every hour and
all that kind of stuff. Same way with
fences. Um they they didn't have to stay
up all night to keep the horse in the
backyard,
okay? They just put a fence around the
house and let him stay in there. So that
was kind of an AI thing and there's AI
things that are good. What started doing
bad things with AI was physicians said,
"Well, this is easy. We'll just do AI
for patients."
And um but when a patient comes in with
diabetes, they don't just have diabetes.
They have high blood pressure. They have
arthritis. They have osteoporosis. They
have liver problems. They have brain
problems. They have eye problems. and
you're just giving them a a prescription
drug to deal with the with the diabetes.
All these other things continue on and
they're going to die 10 to 15 to 20
years early because you haven't really
fixed the basic stuff. And so this is
where the AI thing uh in medicine you
have to
deal with all of the problems going on,
not just the one that the patient is
complaining about. You have to deal with
it all. And this little um it's only a
half hour long, okay?
And it talks about the AI. And the one
that came out first was Dead Doctors
Don't Lie. And that book when it came
out, I don't know, 30 years ago,
we sold before the book came out, we we
had audio tapes. We didn't have CDs yet.
We had audio tapes. We sold 40 million
copies in 81 countries of this of the U
audio tape Dead Doctors Don't Lie. Then
the book came out, Dead Doctors Don't
Lie. And we sold 347 million copies of
that when it's still flying out the door
by the cases and the bags and tens and
20s. Okay, dead Doctors Don't Lie. And
then we came out with a big DVD. This is
two hours and um let's see 2 hours and
10 minutes long. Dead doctors don't lie.
Um someone someone should go to jail.
That's Dr. Milan's favorite subtitle.
Someone should go to jail for this.
Okay. And this is a beautiful thing um
just to have on your desk on your glass.
Don't don't just leave it on the desk
and somebody will walk away with it, but
put it under glass so they can't take
it. But there it is. That's what it
looks like. 2 hours and 8 minutes. It's
a beautiful pre It's my presentation.
It's my presentation. It goes back 10,
15 years ago. And of course, you get a
nice discount when you buy more. And of
course, then the dead don't lie CD.
And now we have the now we have the the
AI thing in a DVD. Okay. And so we have
all this information that will help you
get through this stuff because we know
that none of this is genetic.
It's all nutritional deficiencies and
doctors didn't get the training. So when
they saw PE five people in the family
with the same disease, oh it's got to be
genetic. You had all these people in
your family with it. It's got to be
genetic. No, that's because they're all
eating the same diet, drinking the same
water and so forth.
And you know the example I can give you
this is this right now is the Pakistanis
the Hanzas in the Himalayan mountains
their average lifespan is 120 they have
no medical doctors in the Hanza
communities no medical doctors but they
do live in the land flowing with milk
and honey which is in the old Bible
2 years ago talked about the land
flowing with milk and honey where people
live to be 120 150 300 400 500 because
they're getting all these minerals
coming down from the mountains and it
looked like milk coming down on the side
of the mountains because of the white
powder, the glaciers grinding up the
rocks into dust and that white dust
getting in the in the creeks coming down
the side of the mountains from a half a
mile away. It looked like milk coming
down the side of the mountains. That
where they that's where they got the
term the land flowing with milk and
honey. The minerals getting down into
the mountains into the valleys and the
bees were there because there's more
flowers, more bees, more honey. And so
that's why it was a land flowing with
milk and honey. They didn't know why,
but they knew there was something
special about those places and that's
why it was a God's thing, which is true.
>> Yeah. The Old Testament, Dr. Wallik, in
the beginning, they were living till 900
plus years.
>> Yes.
>> Very commonly well into the 600s and
500s and 400s.
>> Yes.
>> And over time, it's
>> that's because they're getting they were
getting the nutrients coming down from
the sides of those mountains. And so
when you knew that in you know 400 miles
away there those people are living five
times longer than the people in your
community people would move there just
like the Pakistanis okay and the Huns uh
people are flocking to go there because
they're living so long now in the United
States the average lifespan of an
American is 75.7
the average lifespan of a white medical
doctor in America is 75.7 the average
lifespan of a black medical doctor in
America is 65.7
because they're just eating food. Plants
only need three minerals. We need 60.
So, you must supplement because you're
not living in the land flowing with milk
and honey. You have to create your own
environment in your home and your
workplace. And that's why we came out
with all these products.
>> Well, Dr. Wallik, I am so thankful that
you did because now we know that we're
getting in our body when we
intentionally supplement, we're getting
what the body absolutely needs. And
through all of those autopsies, almost
30,000 autopsies, so 452
different species, you were able to
identify the essential, meaning our body
can't make it. They have to be
intentionally taken. And that's what you
and the formulators of the Youngevity
products have done. You have
intentionally made sure that those 90
essential nutrients are in
every dose.
>> That's right. The healthy brain and
heart pack, the healthy start pack, the
healthy bone and joint pack. Okay. Those
three contain the 90. Okay. And then of
course we have um I think it's 2500
secret sauces.
[laughter]
2500.
>> We have we have fewer than that. We have
fewer than that, Dr. Wally, because
we're Yeah. But because some of that
2500 has to do with what I put on my
face, doc,
>> come on. Not everybody can wear the same
colors I wear and I can't wear the same
colors everybody else wears. So, we have
to have a lot of color. Uh, but I love
the fact that it also is mineralbased
and it's just um I know that I'm putting
stuff that's healthy for my skin on my
skin, which brings me to the plant
derived minerals. Dr.
So dry minerals was one of the big that
you had started to talk about. You have
the bottle there. If you don't, I
probably do behind me. But I have my
spray bottle, Dr. Wick, filled with
plant derived minerals. When I get out
of the shower, I spray my body. When I
just want to freshen up,
I spray my face. I spray it in my hair
to get that like beach look type thing.
Yeah, Dr. Dr. Wallik is showing the
planter minerals on the back it lists
all of the elements that are found
within that one bottle and they're
colloidal far form meaning
>> and derived colloidal minerals
>> meaning they get absorbed like
instantly. The body doesn't have to
break down rocks. It's already been
decomposed through the plants and in a
prehistoric vein where it's hidden in
Utah free from contaminants which I
think is fantastic put in that bottle
suspended in liquid which makes it super
easy us for us to take internally and to
spray on the body externally
>> and we have contracts with the minds to
produce this
>> now you can you can buy one bottle
there, but you can't fill your truck
from there because we have a contract
that they can't sell in quantity to
anybody else but us. This has been going
on for like 25 years, okay? Because we
knew that some big corporation would
come swooping in there and kick us out
of there and take over and everything
and we didn't
>> ruin a good thing. [laughter]
Ruin a good thing. Let's not ruin a good
thing. Let's continue to help people.
Dr. Wall. Now, as I'm as we're talking,
we've got all these questions coming in.
And one of the questions is says, "Are
you saying no Christmas cookies?" Well,
one thing about taking the 90 essential
nutrients and the plant dry minerals and
the sweeties that reduces your cravings
for them, so you can have more control
over what you put in your body when it
does come to that whole table full of
goodies. So, if you're eating all those
goodies and you're on the 90 essential
nutrients, it's because you've told your
brain it's okay. It's not that your
body's craving it. Your brain has been
programmed to it. [snorts] Um, so
definitely want to reduce sugar. We've
got Dr. Wallik is holding up the
rebound, which folks, if you're craving
something that's sweet, rebound is a
great uh drink powder that you can mix
in your drink. Gives you hydration. It's
the best electrofuel.
Um, not electro all your vitamins.
You're getting
>> electrolytes.
Electrolytes. So, electrofuel is another
one of the products that Young offers,
but you're getting all your minerals.
You're getting some vitamins in there.
Helps with energy. And a lot of people,
Dr. Wolic, use sugar as energy when in
fact fat is a much better energy and it
lasts longer without having a high and a
crash and not affecting your blood
sugar. So, just something to think
about, folks. And as we're going through
the different things that are um on that
table,
wheat, barley, rye, and oats are heavy
in the baking process. Dr. wallet for
common now for common practice. But
there are so many different amazing
gluten-free flowers that you can do a
cup for a cup and just start
substituting out as you're baking.
Substitute out that regular allpurpose
wheat flour or oat flour. Don't use
oats. It's just as bad as wheat, no
matter what they say. And you want the
good cholesterol to stay there. You
don't want the oat and the fibers
pushing it through the system not
allowing it to be utilized by the liver
so that you can
>> Why is why is why is cholesterol so
valuable?
>> Because cholesterol is needed Dr. olic
to to make the protective coating of the
brain and the myelin sheath and hormones
whether it's estrogen or testosterone
it's it's me it's needed in so many
different functions of the body so if
you cut it out those other functions of
the body are getting cut out too
>> yeah cholesterol is one of your best
friends gives you good sex life gives
you good brain and spinal cord function
and nerve function um doctors do so many
um surgical procedures
because there's osteoporosis of the
skull squeezing those 12 pairs of
cranial nerves and you're not getting
all the the information from the brain
past the skull. It's all locked in there
and doctors want to do surgery and all
this kind of stuff when really you get
on the nutritional program and take
everything perfectly and you can
actually rebuild that skull, go take it
back to normal. It'll take you a couple
of months, but you'll see benefit within
a couple of weeks and just gets better
and better and better by the time the
two. That's why I always say give us 90
days because I found out that 99.9% of
the time you're going to get what you're
going to get before 90 days comes along.
Okay?
>> Are you going to have a good start on
it, Dr. Wallik? I mean, that first 90
days, I lost 20 pounds. I no longer had
all of the pain throughout my body. I no
longer had pain even in my hip capsule.
Um, I no longer was having shingles
outbreaks in my eyes and I kept going
and I lost another 70 pounds and my
blood sugar is under control. My hair
looks great, my skin looks great and
I just
>> your stamina and your strength and to be
able to do physical things.
>> Absolutely. It's
>> it's a beautiful thing.
>> Yeah. I mean, I'm able to take care of
my mama. I'm able to to move.
Who needs a man? Not me. Um, but
[laughter]
I I can move. I can do anything and
everything that that's needed in life
and not be held back. And I just Thank
you, Dr. Wall, because there was not a
time that I mean, there was a time where
I was can't couldn't say that.
>> Now, what what did doctors What did
doctors tell you when you were really
having all these problems? What did they
tell you?
Well, they just pushed me off to pain
management, Dr. W. They wanted to give
me more and more pharmaceuticals to to
mask the pain, and I was allergic to
most of them. So, their option would not
work for me, and I wasn't accepting the
fact that
pain management was all there was left
for me.
So, I mean, broke my back, herniated
discs, degenerative bone and disc
disease, all these different things. I'm
like, there's got to be something.
I shouldn't, you know, I'm too young to
feel this old. And this was at 30, Dr.
W. Like, I didn't find you until I was
44.
So, yeah. And then I had hormone issues
after after having a baby in my 40s. But
hey, life is great. Dr. Wallick, my
goodness, we have lots of questions
coming in. Um, the first one we want to
go to is Patty. So, Patty has been
trying to find a way to raise her hand.
Patty, can you unmute yourself?
>> I'm Thank you so much. Sorry about that.
[clears throat]
>> No worries.
>> I actually I'm here with a friend and I
want him to kind of explain his health
stuff and I've been trying to get him on
to do this. So, I'm glad. Thank you for
taking the time with us today.
>> So, go ahead.
>> Yeah. Hello. Um Yes, sir.
>> Tell them what's going on. Yeah,
>> I've had a stroke in 2015 and then I had
a recent stroke less than a year ago and
was hospitalized for a month and it was
very difficult coming out of that one.
Uh
>> numbness in the leg.
>> Yeah, my numbness and swelling in my leg
hasn't gone down. It's gotten worse. I
had two prior to the stroke. I had two
previous heart attacks
and was hospitalized and they couldn't
find out any information on it. They
didn't give me any information in
regards to why I the heart attacks
occurred. Only my hypertension has been
very high up and down for years.
>> Okay, let's stop there. Uh, how old are
you, sir?
>> I am 64.
>> Okay, how much do you weigh?
197.
>> Okay. So, I want you to get off all the
bad foods. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no glutens, no wheat, no
bar oats, no buckwheat, no sugar, no
carbonated drinks. Even the diet ones
got to go. Carbonation neutralizes your
stomach acids. So, you cannot digest
food or absorb minerals. Then you said
195 pounds, 190 pounds, whatever it is.
>> Yeah.
>> You should take two healthy brain heart
packs per month. Two healthy brain and
heart packs per month. Take a full dose
of breakfast, full dose at dinner time.
Then I also want you to take three of
our ultimate daily classic tablets. Take
three of those at breakfast, three at
lunch, three at dinner time. They're
going to help you get blood flowing into
your brain, into your heart, into your
liver, into your kidneys, so forth. And
then um you also need to take the um
let's see here. Let's go ahead and and
take the sweeties. take three of those
twice a day so you can control your
sugar. Uh we want you also to take the
um
I26 there. I was looking for that I26
and that's going to manage the white
matter in your brain and spinal cord and
rebuild the brain and spinal cord. That
includes the optic nerve going to the
eye and the uh the veins coming back and
the nerves coming back from the eye back
into the brain. Okay.
>> What was that called? I26.
>> I26. Yeah.
>> I26.
>> Okay. And they're chewables. I like the
chewables. I take the French vanillaas.
They also come in banana, coconut, which
are one of our bestselling ones.
>> Okay.
>> And take three of those chewables twice
a day. You could even take three three
times a day if you want. Okay.
And let's see here. What What did I
leave out,
Becca? Did I leave anything out?
>> Did you mention the synaptive, Dr.
Wallik?
Oh, synaptive. Yeah, that'll help the
brain talk to everything out there in
the body and everything in the body talk
back to the brain. And also for energy,
you want to use the rebound. Want to use
rebound. I take two of these a day. I
take one before breakfast. I take one
before lunch. You don't want to take it
after 5:00 because it'll keep you up all
night. But this has um the um vitamins
and minerals and uh amino acids and
stuff like that that you won't get any
place else in any energy drink. And this
is actually made for Theo Ratliff, one
of our best basketball players. Okay.
And we did great things for him. His
career was over. We rebuilt him and he
wanted an energy drink, so we came up
with a rebound for him. And um it comes
in boxes of 30. And if you're going to
be taking two a day at your body weight,
you need two of these. um boxes of
rebound a month and I have to pay for it
like everybody else. I don't get it for
free,
>> right? Okay.
>> Um I'm having a lot of retention
problems in my bladder also.
>> Yeah. Well, that's where again the I26
is going to help you. is the rebuilding
your skull is going to help you because
the vagus nerve, the the tenth cranial
nerve is formed in the brain, comes
through the skull, goes all the way down
to your toes and sends out branches all
the way down. And
that's why your doctor can't figure out
why you're having all these problems
because it's happening in the tenth
cranial nerve because the this the skull
is squeezing that tenth cranial nerve
and c they'll cut your feet off. If you
have pain and you keep complaining about
they'll just cut your feet off. You
won't have pain in your feet anymore
because your feet are in the garbage
camp,
>> right? It's terrible.
>> Okay. But if you want to rebuild the
brain, you want to rebuild the skull.
>> Uh doctors do not get trained on this.
They laugh. You say, "Oh, they say I
have um Dr. Wallik says I have
osteoporosis skull." They'll slap their
leg and laugh. Say, "Get out of my
office. There's no such thing as
osteoporosis skull." No. Osteoporosis
skull is a very very common thing.
Babies can be born with it. Young kids
there's a there's a disease called
Friedri's atexia. Friedri's atexia is
kind of a paralysis.
>> It's a kind of a paralysis.
Um um and so there was a set of twins.
They weren't identical twins. It was
just in a newspaper just like a week
ago. It was in also Fox News. I tried to
find a phone number of the town they
were from and their last name. They just
said their first names and 3 hours later
they weren't on they weren't on the um
uh Fox News anymore. So they probably
had so many calls they just dropped that
because they didn't have any answers.
Well, Friedri's at taxexia is part of
the osteoporosis of the skull squeezing
[clears throat] the the 12 pairs of
cranial nerves including that tense
cranial nerve also uh partly due to the
um myelin the white matter of the brain
spinal cord going away and that's why we
have um the book uh it's all on your
head. We do have a CD that goes along
with it for the spinal cord. Okay. And
it goes into
There you go. We want to turn to page
six, Becca.
[clears throat]
>> Can we order that from the website?
>> Yeah. Top top one is normal. It's a
quarter of an inch thick. The bottom
one, they've taken the top of the skull
off and they're looking at the brain,
but you see that the skull is an inch
and a half to two inches thick. That's
osteoporosis of the skull. The bone has
been replaced by scar tissue and
squeezing all those tunnels. Go ahead,
flip the page. Flip the page.
You're now you're looking at the bottom
of the brain of the human brain. You're
seeing all those those 12 cranial nerves
going out to all the different tissues.
And in in your um left hand, I guess it
is. Uh yeah, there you go. You're seeing
a white bar, a gray bar, a white bar, a
gray bar. Each one of those represents a
chapter. It goes into one of the
cranial nerves and it tells you and
describes those tissues that each nerve
is going to. and then tells you what you
need to add to the what secret sauces
you need to add to the 90 essential
nutrients. Don't just take the secret
sauce because you're not going to get
major benefit. You need to add the
secret sauces to the 90 essential
nutrients. The 90 essential nutrients is
to your body biochemically as water is
to your body as oxygen is your body. You
must have it every day, every minute of
the day. Okay? Don't skip to 90. And
then you add these secret sauces for
each of the problems and you'll be
amazed. In two to four weeks, I had this
problem for 20 years and it went away in
four weeks. Well, what do you think your
doctor knew? Your doctor didn't know
anything about this because they don't
teach about osteoporosis of the skull in
medical school.
>> And Patty, you had asked if you could
get this on the website. Yes, Dr. Wallik
does have it on his website. You can
also find it on Amazon.
>> Oh, okay. Thank you.
>> Majority of Dr. Wallik's books.
>> Of course, you know, the website is
www.drjwallik.com.
www.drjwallik.com
and
you get a hold of these books and CDs
and DVDs and you can, what should I say,
you can add many healthier years to your
life. You can add much health to a life
that's been corrupted by deficiencies
and poor eating habits and where you
live. then you're not living in a in an
area that has glacial milk coming down
the side of the mountain. You may only
have three minerals in your food. Okay?
And somebody who's living where there's
glacial milk coming down the side of the
mountain, they have 75 to 100 minerals
in our food. There's a difference.
>> So, Dr. Wallik, um, we had a question in
here and wanting you to expound on the
American doctor's life expectancy you
said was 75.6, six I believe. Now there
was a there is a time and sometimes it's
still this still holds true where you
had said that a doctor's expectancy was
56 to 58. Now
>> true that is still true for um doctors
who are on the night shift. Okay.
>> Emergency room doctors.
>> Yeah.
Those doctors only live to be 65.
>> Wow.
>> Some of them 56.
Right. Absolutely. Okay. Thank you so
much, Patty, and your guest that you
have there with you.
>> Yes. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah. Give us a call every couple of
weeks because you're going to have a
great story.
>> All right. Dr. Wallik, we're next going
to go over to Rod who has his hand up.
And Rod, what question are you bringing
in for Dr. Wallik today?
>> Hey, good afternoon, Doc. How you doing?
>> Yes, sir. How can we help you?
>> Um, I've had three different calls from
people that dealing with seizures. A
infant, a older lady, and a middle-aged
man. Uh, what's relating or what's
causing these seizures and these people?
If you can help me out. Well, it could
be several things, but a middle-aged
man, um I I believe he probably has
osteopos to the skull and squeezing
um the
12 pairs of cranial nerves in the spinal
cord. Maybe also a version of the
Friedri's atexia having these seizures.
You need to get a hold of the book or
the flip chart. Actually, it's a flip
chart. Okay.
um 90 for life crusade to save humanity
and the world.
>> Okay. And goes into all these things and
you can say, "Oh, that's me. That one's
me." Okay? And it tells you what to
take. Okay? And like I say, we have, I
don't know, about a dozen famous people.
We're talking about movie stars. We're
talking about um athletes that have all
these awards. Okay? We talking about
um very rich people who are successful.
We're talking about um um what should I
say I said movie actors I think. And so
it's one of those things where you have
to look at these people. Why did they
give us their pictures and why are they
telling their stories in this flip
chart? Well, that's because all the best
doctors they could find and spending
thousands of dollars on those doctors
doctor says we can't help you. and they
came to us in weeks. Their problems went
away in weeks, okay? Because they had
osteoporosis of the skull. They had um
all kinds of things going on with the
myelin um and loss of the mile in their
brain and spinal cord. Okay. And so
these are the the sort of things that um
people who uh had Parkinson's disease
for what
years 11 years and then the 12th year
after being on your program for two and
a half months, Dr. Wallik, she no longer
had the symptoms and part of
Parkinson's. It's pretty incredible. Um,
in that uh flip chart, they, you know,
we've got testimonials where there's
neurological conditions where there was
unexplained um
oh twitching throughout the body. Um,
also lungs, asthma, folks. There's so
many different things. As I mentioned,
there's over 600 different poor health
conditions linked to nutritional
deficiencies.
Over 600.
So, chances are what you are
experiencing,
even if it's been something from birth,
because they can pass nutritional
deficiencies through pregnancy onto the
child. It's nutrition is going to be an
answer that you want to give minimum
90-day try because you are going to feel
res.
>> Now go to page 20 27. I think there's
two printings and one of them be on page
26 and another one will be on page 27.
And this is Melinda. Okay. I think
that's
>> so it's Meline and that
>> a case study. We've shared some pi bits
and pieces of a case study of of the
woman we just spoke about that had been
had been diagnosed for 11 years with
Parkinson's. So Dr. Wallak put her on a
protocol um and hey she just got better
doc
in two and a half months she was
diagnosed as free. They tried keep they
kept running all the tests because they
thought they were getting data from
somebody else. when they found out it
was her dad that kept coming in, they
said, "We don't know why, but you don't
have Parkinson's disease anymore after
11 and a half years, getting worse and
worse and worse." And they told her
family she was going to die, you know,
within a couple of weeks. And so that
was several years ago now. And she's
running around the world telling her
story.
>> Absolutely, Dr. Wallik. And we love the
fact that she allowed us to be able to
help use her story to help others as
well. All right, [snorts] doc. We only
have uh less than 15 minutes and I have
about 40 questions here. Seriously.
Seriously. Um so when it comes to let's
see like we're going back to blood
sugar. My mother has diabetes also
dementia. Is it still worth taking
supplements?
>> Oh yes, absolutely. Take the 90
essential nutrients. Get rid of all the
bad foods. Take the healthy brain and
heart pack. Take the sweeties. take the
I26
and all those problems can go away.
>> So whether it's the blood sugar, whether
it's dementia, supplementation
can be very helpful, folks.
>> That's correct.
>> The next one, um, Mr. Appleskin says,
"My doctor, my I'm dealing with rosacea
on my nose. What can I do?"
>> Okay, well, you need to get rid of all
the bad foods. Take the 90 essential
nutrients according to your body weight.
And then um you need to take the
ultimate daily classic tablets that'll
get good circulation all over the body,
whether it's your heart, whether it's
your nose, whether it's your kidneys,
whether it's your brain, whether it's
your eyes, and it's your skin. And we
also do have hair, skin, and nails.
Wouldn't hurt to take hair, skin, and
nails. Get the circulation going through
the skin. Also, in addition to the um uh
let's see, what is it?
>> The ultimate daily classic.
>> The ultimate daily classic. Yeah.
>> And also enzymes, Dr. Wallik, a lot of
times, especially if we've been eating
oats and the foods that we're not
supposed to, we've got to get our
digestive system working again. And the
ultimate enzymes are very beneficial in
helping with that, especially if you
don't have a gallbladder. But it's not
just for those who do not have a
gallbladder. It is for everyone.
>> Yeah. Ultimate Enzymes. Uh I take two of
those. Um well, I take that back. I take
three of those twice a day. The ultimate
enzymes. I take them before the meals.
So, they're waiting for the food to come
down there. You don't want to take your
enzymes after you eat because they'll be
chasing the food and never get get it
done right. So, they you want to take
your enzymes say 10 15 minutes before
you start eating.
>> Absolutely. Then if you forget your
enzymes and you're after a meal and
you're just feeling horrible, digest FX.
That's the ticket.
Um but prevention of feeling horrible is
better than the than the being pro being
reactive. It's better to be proactive.
Next um statement is uh from Olga. She
uses her spray bottle in with the
minerals as well. So thank you Olga for
sharing that.
Um,
so there's another person says,
"So we're not supposed to eat the foods
on the bad foods list, right, Dr.
Wallik?"
>> That's correct. You cannot eat the foods
on the bad food list
>> because those are things
>> that'd be like that'd be like throwing
dirt from Texas into your gas tank of
your car and wondering why it doesn't
work. Come on. That's that's dirt from
Texas is bound to have some gasoline in
it. No, but there's, you know, when you
start doing silly things, that's what it
sounds like. It's pretty silly.
>> So, yes, it is very silly. Um, so
Shirley wants to know, Dr. Well, and
let's let's just go over a protocol
because we we were talking about sugar
today. Um, she wants to know what would
be the products for a diabetic senior to
take. So if she's 150 pounds,
>> okay, 150 pounds, get get rid of get Oh,
I'm sorry. Go ahead.
>> Let me just insert here. So as Dr.
Wallik is giving recommendations, the
way that the formulas have been
packaged, they're packaged for a 30-day
supply for a 100 pound individual. Up we
go to up about Dr. Wallet goes to about
140 pounds. So at 150 pounds, you're
doubling the recommendation. And that's
why he says two brain and heart packs.
So, Dr. Wallik, diabetic senior, is it
going to be different for a senior as it
is for a young person with diabetes?
>> No, you have to get rid of the bad
foods. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no gluten, no wheat
baros, no buckwheat, no sugar, no
carbonated drinks. Okay? Even the diet
one's got to go. Then they need per 100
pounds of body weight they need one
healthy brain and heart pack or one
healthy start pack or one healthy bone
and joint pack whichever one they need
to use. Um and it could be for financial
reasons or or particular um health
problems. And then they need to take the
I26 for the brain and spinal cord to
work properly. Uh they also need to um
take the uh let's see for the heart um
they need the cardio effects they also
need the ultimate daily classic tablets
for blood flow into the brain into the
heart into the kidneys blood pressure
all that kind of stuff. The ultimate
daily classic tablet. It covers a lot of
territory. I take three of those twice a
day. Ultimate Daily Classic tablets. And
um it's I only weigh 142 pounds. And um
for snacks um I use our we have our
chocolate. Okay. I've just got a big
supply in. Okay. Triple tree truffles.
Triple tree truffles. Okay. And just
take a little package out. Uh it comes
one truffle per package there. And of
course, I'm gonna have one after lunch.
>> I figured you were gonna open it right
now and just tease us with it. But I
love the do the Young Jevity chocolate,
Dr. Well, because one, it gives you
calcium. Two, it gives you pre and
probiotics as well in addition to those
antioxidants that are naturally found in
real cacao.
>> So, yeah, good.
>> And it tastes good. It is low in sugar.
Of course, um people like their
chocolates to be on the sweet side, so
there's a little bit of natural cane
sugar added in there to give a little
bit of sweetness.
>> Yeah, you taste the chocolate, but it
doesn't taste just like sugar. This it
should taste like chocolate. And it's a
very unique flavor. And um it's what
should I say? It's a about a I don't
know quarter of an inch thick in the
shape of a heart. It's really really
nice. And so
>> yeah, it's actually
about almost a half an inch thick.
That's pretty pretty good size chocolate
there. Dr. Wick, we've got some more
questions. Um, so James wants to know,
there you go. James wants to know, um,
what should I take with Oh, you're mean.
Can you listen and hold I thought that
you were putting that in your mouth.
>> Ready?
>> Yeah.
>> What should I take with tricep muscle
soreness?
He has he's 52 pounds or 52 years 155
pounds. Um he has been taking the start
pack and collagen peptides. What else
should he be taking Dr. Wallik for the
muscle soreness?
>> My question is he just start working out
or has this been ongoing?
>> Okay, that's a good question. But in the
meantime, he can put we have our CM
cream. He can rub that on his shoulder
and also the triceps which come down
from the shoulder. Okay. And um but also
he needs to put it on his neck and he
needs to take the I26
so his um brain and spinal cord are
working properly. He also needs the um I
go with the the gluccoel. make sure he's
getting three of glucagel three times a
day to deal with the um
vertebral disc between the vertebrae
including that includes the ones in the
neck. Okay? And because the neck uh
afflicts the arms. Okay?
There you go. And so there's a reason
why you're feeling sore there. Okay?
>> And it may not necessarily be muscle. It
could be a referred pain because of the
nerves.
>> Yeah. Could the process of the skull
squeezing that that vagus nerve that
tense cranial nerve and that branch is
being squeezed as it's coming out of the
skull.
>> All right. Um Dr. Wallik next. So Wendy
writes in. She says, "First, I'd like to
say thank you. I've been taking your
longevity products for two months now
and have an overall feeling of wellness.
Joint pain is an issue. your bone and
joy pack is amazing. She's also been on
a subscription, a couple subscriptions,
uh blood pressure and
uh for for retention. Um she takes a
vitamin D. She wants to know if the
drugs are safe to mix with the
pharmaceuticals or if the
pharmaceuticals are safe to mix with the
Youngevity products. She has about 30
pounds um to to let go of and no matter
what she does, it won't come off. She
says,
>> "Here's the deal. Um the nutrients are
just food." Okay? They don't commit or
they don't compete. That's the word I'm
looking for. They don't compete directly
with the pharmaceuticals. The
pharmaceuticals are designed to relieve
a symptom. The nutrients give your body
what it needs to perform a function.
Okay? There's a difference between a
symptom and a function. Okay? And so if
your function is improving, you can
begin to reduce the medication. Don't
just cold turkey off the medication, but
you know, reduce it by say 10, 15, 20%.
Oh man, man, this is wonderful. And then
see what happens in the next week or
two. Okay? And so you want to reduce
your medication slowly based on the
amount of reduction of um the problem
you had.
And so
as the relief of the problem is going
down, you want to slowly increase your
secret sauces. That's why we call them
secret sauces. But you need full doses
of the healthy brain and heart pack. You
need full doses of the of the uh or the
healthy start pack, the healthy bone and
joint pack, whichever one you want. you
need a full dose of that and then the
secret sauces come in. You do it at the
same time, but there, you know, we're
talking about the sweeties and the
ocean's gold and we're talking about um
the glucagel and those kinds of things.
Okay? And so it's it's um in the I26, we
need those things. And you can increase
the dosage as you're getting better and
decrease your your um decrease. Don't
just cold turkey off your medication,
but decrease it by say 10%. Or decrease
it by 25%. And if you're still feeling
better the next day again next week, you
reduce it some more and so forth. And it
may take you that's why I say give us 90
days because you should be able to get
maximum benefit from an exchange from
all drugs to reducing your drugs based
on what benefit you're going to get from
the 90s essential nutrients and the
secret sauces.
Now, we do recommend that you do work
with your primary care physician when
you have been prescribed a
pharmaceutical. We want to make sure
that they are in awareness of what you
are doing. And as your chemicals are
working in the body, the supplementation
makes them work better.
>> Meaning, you're going to need as much
until you don't need them at all. Now,
here's a beautiful thing about what you
just said. Because what we want is that
doctor to say, "I don't know why. I've
never seen anybody get rid of this
problem." Well, I'm taking this. Let me
see what you're taking. Okay? And he'll
begin to he or she will begin to give
that to other patients if they're honest
because if it's working for you, it
should work for somebody else. It was
truly what was going on. And so you'll
spread the health um information
by sharing what you're doing if you're
getting the benefit. And uh there'll be
some doctors that just won't do it.
They'll just say, "Well, stop taking all
that nutrition stuff. Just keep taking
the Okay, that that translates to I have
a kid in college and I need the money."
>> Well, I have a couple comments on that.
But
um when it comes to the weight that
won't come off, Wendy, um a lot of times
when we're under a lot of stress, it
raises our cortisol levels. And when our
cortisol levels are high, that does
limit us from being able to lose that
extra weight because the body's kind of
confused. There is a product that been
that was brought in by the Life Force
company that Youngevity just recently
acquired. It's called True Boost. It has
adaptogens
that help with balancing cortisol levels
out. So, I have started taking this. It
It doesn't taste bad.
>> You want it like this?
>> Yeah.
>> Or like this.
>> Like that. There you go. True boost.
>> There you go.
>> And it does come. This is a single dose.
Um, so definitely want to try that and
see how that works for you. Now, Dr.
Wallik, you know, back to uh wanting you
to stop taking pharmaceuticals. There's
a recent publication that came out, Dr.
Wallik, that has shown vitamin C to be
beneficial in the cases of cancer. Ty
tangerine is loaded with vitamin C. Not
just vitamin C, but also all of the
co-actors that the body needs to be able
to properly process that vitamin C at
the cellular level, folks.
>> Again, which product is that?
>> Tangy Tangerine.
>> I know. I just wanted to hear you say it
again.
>> Well, which one do you want me to say?
Because there's a tangy tangerine that
is shellfish free for those that are
having problems with shell shellfish.
We've got the tanky tangerine 2.0 which
has the pre and probiotics in it. We
also have the 2.5 for those that have
been told that they have an MTHFR
mutation. We've got the 2.5 version of
the Beyond Tangy Tangerine. We now have
the 3.0 O which breaks down the
nutrients so that you have a morning
dose, you have an evening dose. Those
nutrients that help work best as you are
in rest as it is called restore. The
other one is called rise. I actually
have them right there. Um we also have
the originals Dr. Wallik. We've got the
ultimate tangy tangerine which is a
concentrate. That's the one that I
actually have taken most um throughout
my longevity experience because I was in
the pig pack plus. There's also the
ultra body totty which is another form
of the tangy tangerine product. The
ultra body totty has shell cell shield
blend in it which I absolutely in love
what benefits that brings to the body as
well. Again that's ultra body totty.
There's the ultimate classic which was
the original. Dr. Wick, we're out of
time. Actually, we went over time. So, I
just want to thank you and a quick
little shout out for an event that is
being held this weekend on Saturday. You
want some more information about that?
It is impact.ailywithdoc.com.
um as it is going to be a special
presentation that is directed towards
those in the medical practitions of
modalities modalities health and
wellness folks
>> Rebecca
>> that's on Sunday
>> Sunday thank you that's why I have my
co-host team um it's on Sunday which is
fantastic because that gives me two more
days to prepare but folks we're gonna
have pharmacist Ben on there I've got a
special segment from Dr. Wallik that was
pre-recorded that's going to be included
in that um plus some others. You don't
want to miss this. Share this with your
friends and family whether they're a
chiropractor, massage therapist.
>> When is this going to be?
>> This is Sunday. Dr. Wallik,
>> it's coming Sunday.
>> It's coming Sunday. It is going to be 2
o'clock Pacific time. But get all of the
information by going to
impact.dwithdoc.com.
You do have to register for it to get
the link to join the Zoom. So, Dr. Well,
I know you've got to go. Thank you so
much for all that that you do. I'm going
to go ahead and release you. Have a
fantastic day, Doc. We love you. We
appreciate you so much.
>> Well, thank you. Thank you. We love you,
too. I can't thank you and the team
enough and thank all the callers for
participating. God bless each and every
one of you. Share the messages. Let's
save humanity and the earth. We back
again. Bye bye.
>> Absolutely. Many, many years to come,
Doc. Bye for now. And if I could get my
co-host up on the screen with me, I
greatly appreciate them. um as I
couldn't keep track of everything all by
myself. All of the questions that were
coming in from YouTube, from Rumble,
through email, um here in the Zoom, it's
just
I have to apologize for those that we
did not get to. So, please email us at
questionsailywithdoc.com.
We will make sure that you do get
answers
to your questions based on Dr. Wallik's
research and recommendations.
He is the leader. He is the one that
started this crusade. He's the one that
did all of the research and was
instrumental in the original
formulations of the products that
Youngevity offers. they have found value
in other products that they have brought
into that umbrella under Young because
they have things that maybe weren't
there in the Youngevity
family of products and instead of trying
to recreate the wheel, they found
something that already was created and
they were able to bring that company and
help build them stronger into the
Youngevity family. So, thank you
everybody,
everybody for being here with us,
investing just over an hour into your
own health for yourself, your family,
your community. And as you're taking
action,
all together, we can make an impact and
change how the world
is. I mean, there's poor health all
around the world. United States, I
think, is probably the one of the
sickest, which is really sad because we
have the most money going into our
healthcare.
But folks, when it's nutritional
deficiencies, their pharmaceuticals are
not going to fix you. They're going to
mask the symptoms. So, we invite you to
give us 90 days. Give Dr. Wallik 90
days. get back with the person that
shared this program with you and say,
"Hey, I want to try this at least 90
days, okay? You're going to be feeling
the difference." And as Dr. Wallik
[clears throat] said, it's like putting
gas in your car. You got to keep it
going
in order to maintain
your body's ability to not just survive,
but thrive. So [snorts] today we have on
with us Ruth Ellen who she is my
executive production manager. Thank you
so much Ruth Allen for all that you do
and helping us stay organized and get
this Zoom put together and pushed out
onto the different platforms. We
appreciate you. We have Sherry who is
part of that getting everything ready to
push out to the different platforms. So
thank you Sherry as you get that help
get that set up. We have AJ who I don't
think is on with us. He had to take off.
Um he is responsible for g getting those
platforms available for us and set up so
that we do and can push out to the
different platforms. We have Marilyn who
is with us today as she is transcribing
and typing super duper fast and her
little fingers at work here. She's
taking lots of collagen and glucco gel
folks to help keep those muscles,
tendons, ligaments, and osteoporosis
from not affecting her body as she is
doing this repetitive work. So, thank
you so much Marilyn for all you do. And
we have Albert joining us from down in
South Africa and that is his friend that
lives in his yard that we call him
Marty. Um he is here letting people into
the Zoom room. Um, so thank you so much,
Albert, as it is late at night for you.
We appreciate you being here. And we
also have Rod who is here. He's out
watching the different platforms,
looking for those comments and questions
and bringing them into the Zoom and is
our backup. So Albert's the bouncer. Rod
is the backup bouncer when it comes to
bringing people into the room and
keeping an eye on stuff for us. So, you
know, we greatly appreciate all of you
being on your best behavior. You don't
know how much we appreciate that as you
are coming in and allowing it to be an
environment where people can pay
attention and learn. [snorts] So, folks,
get back with the person that shared
this program with you. If there is no
one to thank, we have a call team
standing by at 855-9493377.
Again, 855-9493377.
Um, we have certified holistic health
coaches that do man that phone line. But
again, if you were referred by somebody
specific or if you're currently taking
the Young Jevity products already, get
back with your Young distributor. All
right? We want to make sure that they
are taking care of you because that's
what this business is all about is
helping others. And as we're helping
others, we know that you'll start
helping others as well. And let's work
together to make a healthy healthier
world. My name is Becca Dukes. As the
director of student services for the
Institute of Holistic Health, I would be
doing you an injustice not mentioning
the fact that we have a certified
holistic health coach course that is
open and available to everybody. Even if
you don't want to be a health coach,
this information is something that you
can comply
in your own world for your own health
and the health of your families.
50% off right now, folks. It's already
an affordable price. Compared to other
programs that are out there, it is a
tenth of the price. And then you do 50%
off of that and oh my goodness, a fifth
of the price. You can become a certified
holistic health coach. But most
importantly, you can gain the knowledge
that is needed to help you sustain a
life to thrive. Get back with a person
that shared this program with you. You
can also sign up at coachwithdoc.
That's coachwithdoc.com.
And if you want the 50% off, give us a
call 855-9493377
as there is a special discount code that
is being offered through Christmas.
After Christmas and after the first of
the year, it will not be available at
50% off. So give us a call 8559493377.
Visit the website, get that good foods,
bad foods list so you know exactly what
should and should not be eaten and why.
We have the why on there as well. And
also check out some of our other
programs. Like and subscribe
if you are on any of our platforms. Make
sure that you're following us and most
importantly share it. We do this so that
it can be shared and used to help create
a healthier world. Tomorrow we do have
with us pharmacist Ben Fuches as we're
going to be bringing more information
going a deep dive into some specific
health concerns as that our listeners
are reaching out to us about. So
have a blessed day everybody and we'll
see you next time on Daily with Doc. Bye
for now.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. The
content is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any diseases,
[music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials [music] are shared as
individual experiences of the individual
sharing their testimony. Results vary
and [music] may not be typical. We do
not make any claims regarding health or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to have the founding [music]
father of the science of epigenetics
guiding us with the best options to
obtain or maintain optimal health, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. The
content is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any diseases,
[music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials are shared as [music]
individual experiences of the individual
sharing their testimony. Results vary
and [music] may not be typical. We do
not make any claims regarding health or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to have the founding [music]
father of the science of epigenetics
guiding us with the best options to
obtain or maintain optimal health, Dr.
Joel Wallik.